The first option--use dropdowns to limit what the users can actually enter--
yes, that makes sense.
In fact, when you fill out your date online, I'm sure they usually have dropdowns
for month, day, and year because that simplifies things a little bit.
But no matter what we do, we also need to verify what the user enters
and complain if the data is bad because as we talked about before,
just because our form limits what the user can actually enter,
a malicious user or somebody goofing around can make a form that posts to
any URL they want, including our server, and they can put in whatever junk they want,
and they very well could break our server verification.
A lot of forms--a lot of websites out there think just because they use dropdowns
that they don't have to verify the data on the backend.
So have fun out there playing with that.